EXCUSE THAT GAS IS SPIKING
BACK UP.
>> EVERY KITCHEN TABLE COST IS
GOING TO GO UP AND NOT DOWN. I
REALIZE COSTS GOING UP
CONCLUDED. I WAS ABLE TO BRING
GASOLINE DOWN BUT IT IS INCHING
UP BECAUSE OF WHAT THE RUSSIANS
DID AND THE SAUDIS JUST DID. I
AM NOT FINISHED WITH THAT YET.
JOINING ME NOW IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR OF THE
"WEISSMANN WHO FOUND CHRISTMAS"
AND WITH ME IS LISA BOOTHE.
>> HI RACHEL.
>> NICE TO HAVE BOTH OF YOU
TONIGHT. I THINK HE WAS TRYING
TO BLAME PUTIN BUT I DON'T
THINK HE KNOWS HOW TO DO THAT
RIGHT ANYMORE.
>> THE RUSSIANS AND THE SAUDIS
SHOULD BE VERY WORRIED, RACHEL,
HE SAID I AM NOT FINISHED WITH
THAT YET. MAYBE HE'S GOING TO
TANK THEIR ECONOMY, TOO. SO,
STAY TUNED FOR THAT. LOOK, THE
REASON THAT WE ARE IN THIS
PICKLE AND WE ARE SEEING THE
GAS PRICES GOING THROUGH THE
ROOF, IT IS NOT THE RUSSIANS OR
THE SAUDIS. THOSE PRICES WERE
GOING UP LONG BEFORE THEY DID
ANYTHING. THIS IS JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES. I SPOKE TO AN OIL
EXECUTIVE HERE IN LOUISIANA
TODAY AND HE WAS TELLING ME THE
LAST TIME THEY HAD EXPLORATION
LEASES, AN AUCTION WAS UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION. WHEN
BIDEN CAME IN, HE LURED ALL
THOSE LEASES EVEN THOUGH THESE
COMPANIES PAID FOR THEM.
REMEMBER DONALD TRUMP WANTED TO
BUY 77 MILLION BARRELS FOR OUR
STRATEGIC RESERVE. IT WAS THE
DEMOCRATS WHO STOPPED THAT.
THAT WAS ONLY $15 A BARREL.
TODAY WE ARE IN A REAL PICKLE
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN DECIDED TO
NOT ONCE BUT TWICE BUT FOUR
TIMES, HE'S ZAPPED THAT
STRATEGIC RESERVE WERE DOWN A
THIRD OF WHAT IT WAS AND HE
WANT TO GO BACK TO THE WELL
AGAIN. AMERICANS SHOULD SAY NO.
>> YOU MADE SUCH A GREAT POINT.
THAT AT THE HEART OF ALL OF
THESE ARE THESE GREEN POLICIES.
THEY ARE CRUEL. THEY ARE MAKING
PEOPLE POOR ON PURPOSE. IS IT
TIME TO CALL OUT AS
CONSERVATIVES. THEY WANT TO
SACRIFICE OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
ABILITY TO PASS ON WEALTH TO
THEM OR JUST FEED SO MANY
AMERICANS ON THE ALTER OF THESE
GREEN POLICIES. WHAT IS IT
ABOUT? IS IT ABOUT CONTROL OR
SOCIALISM? WHAT IS IT?
>> I THINK IT IS ABOUT CONTROL.
THE PAIN IS THE POINT. THAT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING TO
REALIZE ABOUT THE LEFT
POLICIES. THE PAIN IS THE
POINT. THE POINT OF THE LEFT
POLICIES, WHAT THEY'RE TRYING
TO DO IS GUT THE MIDDLE CLASS
AND CREATE A LARGER PORTION OF
THE POPULATION THAT ARE
DEPENDANT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THAT'S WHAT THESE
POLICIES ULTIMATELY DO IS GUT
THE MIDDLE CLASS. ALL THESE
PROBLEMS, ALL THESE ISSUES THAT
WE FACE AS A COUNTRY ARE
SOLVABLE, SO MUCH SO THAT EYE
DEN COULD GET IT. YOU HAVE TO
SIT HIM DOWN AND GIVE HIM ICE
CREAM AND SPEAK SLOWLY AND HE
COULD GET IT. YOU DON'T WANT
YOUR CITY TO BE OVERRUN. PUT
CRIMINALS BEHIND BARS. YOU
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO PAY SO
MUCH FOR GAS PRICES, UNLEASH
AMERICAN ENERGY PRODUCTION. YOU
GO DOWN THE LIST, THE SOLUTIONS
ARE SO SIMPLE BUT THAT TAKES IT
BACK TO MY POINT THAT THE PAIN
OF THE POINT, IT IS
INTENTIONAL. THEY DON'T WANT TO
SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS. THEY
DON'T WANT TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS, THEY ARE CREATING
THEM.
>> IT IS JUST TWO YEARS AGO, WE
WERE JUST ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
WE WERE NET EXPORTERS OF ENERGY
AND NOW WE ARE BEGGING THE
SAUDIS, GETTING DIRTY OIL
AGAIN. MORE OF THE HYPOCRISY
AGAIN, GETTING OIL FROM
VENEZUELA. I UNDERSTAND WHAT
LISA IS SAYING ABOUT MAKING US
MORE INDEPENDENT. I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH THAT. THE CONTROL
PART IS MOVING FORMS OF ENERGY
THAT THEY CAN TURN ON AND OFF
ON US, THEY CAN CONTROL AND
THAT WE'LL EVENTUALLY BE ON
SOME SORT OF CHINESE-STYLE
SOCIAL CREDIT SYSTEM, OR UNLESS
WE AGREE WITH WHAT THESE BIG
GLOBALISTS WANT. WE DON'T GET
TO DRIVE OUR CARS OR TRAINS.
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CHINA RIGHT NOW.
>> IT IS ABOUT FREEDOM. OUR
ABILITY TO MOVE AND CREATE, I
MEAN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
MANUFACTURING BASE IN THE
UNITED STATES, BIDEN WAS
TALKING ABOUT, HE COULD NOT SAY
MADE IN AMERICA. THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THE ONLY THING THAT'S
MADE IN AMERICA IS INFLATION
AND NATIONAL SECURITY. BECAUSE
OF THESE POLICIES AND WHEN YOU
ARE BEGGING HAT AND HAND THESE
REGIMES IN SAUDI ARABIA AND
VENEZUELA TO GIVE YOU A CUP OF
OIL BECAUSE YOU CAN'T AND WON'T
DRILL YOUR OWN, THAT'S A HUGE
PROBLEM. IT LOCKS THE PEOPLE
DOWN. SOMEHOW WE HAVE TO GET
PASS THIS COLT OF GREEN NEW
DEAL THAT BIDEN DECIDED TO I AM
EMBODIED AND EMBRACED. IT
DESTROYED OUR INDUSTRY AND MADE
US VERY INSECURE.
>> ABSOLUTELY. THEY GIVE HIM
THE FINGER.
>> WE CAN DO IT HERE AND BE
INDEPENDENT. YOUR POINT OF
CONTROL, LOOK AT CALIFORNIA,
RACHEL, THEY'RE SAYING HEY YOU
CAN'T GO OUT AND BUY A GAS
POWERED CAR BY 2035. BUT, BY
THE WAY, WE ARE GOING TO TELL
YOU WHEN YOU CAN CHARGE YOUR
ELECTRIC VEHICLE. THE REALITY
IS GETTING RID OF FOSSIL FUELS
IS A DEATH MISSION. IT IS GOING
TO LEAD TO DEATH AND HUMAN
SUFFERING. IT IS NOT A BETTER
WAY OF LIFE, IT LEADS TO A
WORSE WAY OF LIFE. THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT ANY OF THIS STUFF.
THAT'S THE KICKER. THEY BEEN
ABLE TO GET SO MANY AMERICANS
TO BUY INTO THEIR CLIMATE
HOPES, THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT
IT. LOOK AT HOW MANY OF THEM
FIGHT PRIVATE, IT IS A JOKE TO
THEM. IT IS ABOUT CONTROL TO
THEM. THE REALITY IS THEY'RE
ALL GOING TO BE FLYING PRIVATE
WHEN YOU CAN'T PAY FOR YOUR
GAS. WHEN THEY'RE DRIVING UP
GAS PRICES BY GETTING RID OF
THINGS LIKE THE KEYSTONE AND
NOT ALLOWING AMERICAN ENERGY
PRODUCTION TO DO THEIR THING.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FLYING
PRIVATE, YOU CAN'T USE
ELECTRICITY BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
AFFORD OR IT IS NO LONGER
ABUNDAN
ABUNDANT.
>> THAT'S THE REALITY.
>> LISA MAKES A GREAT POINT.
THAT'S A GREAT POINT THAT LISA
IS MAKING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> BETWEEN THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE AND OUR OWN
POPULATION, WE COULD MAKE UP
THE OILS THAT THE SAUDIS AND
RUSSIA ARE TAKING OFF THE MAP
EASILY, WE ARE NOT DOING IT.
WHY? THAT'S THE QUESTION THAT
EVERY AMERICAN AND
CONGRESSPERSON SHOULD BE
DEMANDING OF THIS